that's something I know
[Music]
sorry
okay
go ready
so I wanna take a second and talking a
little bit more detail about the
incident today and have our police chief
give a little bit more information about
what happened today and
information unfold let's just start by
saying it's really tough day for the
city of Jersey City you know these sort
of situations you often hear as we're
discussing that when you lose an officer
they say he was a great officer and
pride in his job and all the great
things about what he did that her as I
said he or she did and in this situation
happens to be true 100% mobsters name is
Joe seals Joe was with the department
since 2006
even more than being a police officer
that love Jersey City that was probably
responsible for or one of the leading
officers for the most guns getting off
the street or when I understand
it's also a husband and a father of five
children so it's a tough day for Jersey
City
Joe is somebody who's involved
the city the officers and other
precincts knew who he was because
turn it over to the director and then
ultimately to the police chief that led
the situation today and maybe explain a
little bit more detail what happened
I'll turn over to
chiefly to touch anything michael kelly
ke Oly so today at around 12:30 we
received a call of shots fired in the
area of 2 to 3 MLK Drive Martin Luther
King Drive units responded and were
immediately engaged by high-powered
rifle fire citywide assist was called at
that time we were learning at the same
time that we had another officer down in
another part of the city down on
Garfield Avenue by Cavin point I don't
know the exact address that officers
since been listed as deceased that is
Joseph seals detective what our cease
fire you [ __ ] Joe it a little pig our
unit set up a perimeter two to three MLK
we had a citywide assist you call for
mutual aid from our partners partners
began with the FBI
Port Authority all surrounding
municipalities ATF just about all the
folks that were within earshot of us
responded
at that time we've set up a tactical
advantage continue to take gunfire for
hours our offices were under fire for
hours
two more police officers were hit by
gunfire one sustained a injury to the
shoulder once sustained another injury
to the body those officers have since
been released from the hospital
they are ray Sanchez and paronella
Fernandez once again we're happy they're
alright however Joseph seals succumbed
to the gunshot wounds that he received
at that time we started to piece some
information together everything I tell
you is preliminary the investigation
will take weeks maybe months the crime
scene is very extensive is it three
locations at least at this time we have
one stolen u-haul via vehicle that may
contain incendiary device that has since
been taken from the location and it's
been examined by a bomb squad members
secondly we have five people do a inside
the store that members of the police
force that set up
eventually we declared them DOA we
believe two of them are bad guys we
believe three of them or not that maybe
civilians that were inside the store
once again this is all preliminary
information but you should know that the
police department in Jersey City and our
partners did an extraordinary job under
very difficult circumstances or the
high-power rifle fire where no other
citizens in Jersey City was struck with
gunfire and our police officers were
brave until finally the threat was
neutralized that's it for now everything
else is
Joseph seals is a veteran police officer
of over 15 years came out now South
District with his took place South
District is a very busy precept
has a high volume of violent crime Joe
sills was promoted to the rank of
detective in the last couple of years a
scientist city's ceasefire unit as the
mayor alluded to he was our leading
police officer in moving guns from the
street dozens and dozens of handguns
he's responsible for movement from the
street as the mayor alluded to also he's
married with children hearts go out to
him and once again we believe that he
was killed
to interdict these bad guys at that
other location on Garfield Avenue once
again this is all being investigated
with guns is that what he was trying to
interdict
we believe yes this is not the cemetery
this was the cemetery this is the
cemetery incident chief there have been
reports that this was part of most
homicide investigation those are all
potentialities they're being looked into
no detective seals was working you know
I really don't want to get into those
details I can just say that he came upon
bad guys and I don't know how he got
there just yet we needed detective he's
a detective you see please yes
yes and I consider the u-haul van a
stolen van crime scene chief this
obviously underscores the danger of
police work I mean today we top resolve
residential neighborhood that basically
turned into a battlefield with these man
and it's high-caliber weapons have you
ever seen anything like this in your
years unfortunately we've had many
incidents where we've lost police
officers and against high-powered
weapons so I'm prefer you to 2009
detective Martin Otto lost his life
forgive me you said to God to bad guys
we both my eyes right now
preliminarily we believe they're both
men
[Music]
preliminary ly we believe they're both
men and only two shooters at this time
there was some talk about it at one
point what did the gunman going on top
of the loops you talk about that we're
not going to get into the details of
four hours of police work but I can tell
you their movement was was rapid and
continuous for four hours within that
area sir could you tell us in relation
to the u-haul vehicle was that stolen
our prior to the incident in the
cemetery or did they hijack that vehicle
and then they went on to the double they
go the groceries detectives are
following that information now we
believe no
that is breed investigated now do you
believe the officers were hit only by
gunfire the suspects believe any of the
victims we do we think that this was all
a bad guy firing even the three dealings
yes when we left the crime scene 25
minutes ago we came down we rushed down
to see detective seals and that family
for morning right now and the rest of
the crime scene was being handled by
deputy chiefs on scene was a detective
ever brought to the hospital where he
was pronounced dead at the scene
I don't know the answer to that one was
struck in the shoulder and the other one
I believe was trucked in the body as far
as don't know the answer to that could
you give us the condition that Officer
Sanchez is in right now sir Sanchez was
released from the hospital
both of correct can you tell us about
those officers what are
they like how many years of service I'm
going to have to defer to that until
later on and don't really know those two
officers I can just tell you they were
very very brave a whole bunch of other
men and women out
no we have no we have no the
investigation is going to continue for a
long time
we have no inkling what the motive was
yet
I need shots fired in this residential
area can you speak to that as difficult
afraid of
for your officers
I think this is a neighborhood that's
open coming this neighborhood has had
challenges and has become much much
safer and better neighborhood over the
last two years or the last three years
or so so we we can only say that folks
that live in a neighborhood are
supportive of the police department and
they were out there today showing their
support wholeheartedly especially for
those officers that are wanted she found
on the suspects and any gang affiliation
are you looking at sort of I just like
to add your name please sir yeah Public
Safety Director James yeah just like
that what the chief said this would be a
horrific incident in any neighborhood
anywhere in the world
but I think it needs to be noted I know
the people in Jersey City noted that
under the Chiefs leadership the police
department immediately was on the scene
interjecting most active shooters and
when the police arrived in this case one
of our officers gave his life
immediately trying to prevent what to
subsequently occurred then two more
officers were shot trying to prevent it
and the Jersey City Police Department
continued to respond and engage his
people to minimize any possible damage
so while this no one wants this to
happen anywhere we don't give anything
to have detectives back and the other
people who passed away but there is no
question that the Jersey City Police
Department did what they are supposed to
do to protect the people in that day
and I'm sure the people in that
neighborhood from abstinence schools in
the area there were schools that went on
lockdown what was the response like for
those schools and to get a sense of what
we were in touch with the Board of
Education immediately and then there
were some schools in the area that were
unaffiliated with the Board of Education
we had a police presence at the schools
actually during the day so it was one of
the first things that we did it and then
we dealt with an active shooter
situation for the better part of four
hours you know for the last three years
we've invested a lot of resources
active shooter situations
this is the second active shooter
situation
in about a year one was at the Newport
and
so while I believe that live the best
Police Department anywhere it's just
unfortunate that we have
business tragic what happened and how
many schools were on lockdown
I don't think that when you see active
shooter situations it's isolated to one
city so my open you should take that we
have best Police Department anywhere and
that was demonstrated today the chief
did a phenomenal job commanding the
situation it was challenging not only to
go to the situation that was there but
he was managing multiple resources state
resources to regarding D there and
phenomenal job
deserves a lot of credit consultation
service means to those other agencies
that were also taking part of this
operation chief it's all the other
police departments that jump in oh my
god
anybody was so blessed to have such fine
law enforcement in the States of Jersey
and I can only tell you some of the
foster agencies we saw there like I said
from the top the FBI we're going to help
New Jersey Essex County Bergen County
jeepers they were all there and
appreciate and I would be remiss if I
didn't tell you that
NYPD responded and NYPD was the most
folks with the best of the business as
well as the New Jersey State Police
that's part of the investigation I can
tell you we have no evidence that's
pointing in that direction at this time
but that's certainly on the table as far
as weapons that was still a hot scene
when I left and we had not recovered the
weapons we heard a lot of engagement
they've got a sense of how many shots
were fired exchanged
rough estimate hundreds can you tell us
how to steal
oh it would be a guest he's got five
children so I'm gonna say he's in his
40s
we don't know that I miss billions
billions
once again that's preliminary you
believe that the three civilians this is
all any time you do a press conference
like this is very very difficult to come
together because the scene is just
breaking down now
so I'm sorry I cannot give you
information on the actors I cannot give
you information on civilians because I
don't know
detective seals family did you speak
the mayor Public Safety Director the
police director of myself went to the
hospital and spoke with detective
shields family and obviously
and our tribute to the Pegasus mayor can
use and you talk to us tonight I am Sam
the tough work identity police officers
do have you seen day to day they put on
that uniform and they take their life
into their own hand
another part of
single day we get reports of guns being
taken off the street and you know most
of the time that's thought without
anybody in danger which speaks to the
type of work that these people do and
they're heroes and
[Music]
I get to test out Ben